paillé en afrique on redoute un nouveau
génocide dans la province du darfour à
l'ouest du soudan
cette région est le siège
d'affrontements permanent entre des
tribus arabes nomades et les fermiers
noirs
dix mille de ces derniers ont déjà été
massacrés plus d'un million ont fui le
pays
la plupart pour se réfugier au tchad où
l'on craint maintenant une contagion du
conflit
jean marc pitte et jack d'énergie elles
ont marché durant six jours à travers le
désert pour parcourir la cinquantaine de
kilomètres qui sépare leur village
soudanais de la frontière tchadienne
d'autres femmes de fara williams qu'il
avait traversé les jours précédents les
accueille et les réconforte
mais c'est avant tout vers ceux qui sont
restés que vont leur pensée c'est plus
de la moitié des gens de notre village
qui a été tué et encore nous ne savons
pas ce que nous sommes sont devenus sur
la route de l'exode
elles sont nombreuses à avoir perdu des
enfants en bas âge qui n'ont pas résisté
à la fatigue à la chaleur et au manque
de nourriture et au bout du parcours
il n'ya que ces abris de branches
rapidement construit autour d'un arbre
pour s'épargner les morsures du soleil
mais tout vaut mieux que des assauts
permanent des militaires soudanais
alliés aux milices des djandjawid ses
cavaliers arabes qui pillent et chasse
de la province du darfour
ceux de ses habitants qui ont la peau
noire ils ont volé nos animaux brûlé nos
maisons c'est pour ça que nous sommes
partis
le tchad s'est montré totalement
solidaire de ces réfugiés
il a accepté l'installation de huit
camps gérés par des organisations non
gouvernementales sur son territoire afin
de les reloger et d'éviter une
catastrophe sanitaire
cette solidarité doit beaucoup à la
parenté des deux peuples
les ethnies touché par la répression
soudanaise comme celles qui l'exercent
sont également présentes au tchad
l'ethnie zaghawa dont sont issus la
plupart des rebelles du darfour est
aussi celle du président du tchad
ils se retrouvent donc tiraillé entre
les pressions des membres de son clan
qui brûle de le voir prendre la défense
de leurs frères du soudan et son désir
d'éviter à la fois un conflit avec son
voisin et une guerre civile sur son
propre territoire
je crains fort que nous prenons des
dispositions qui permettent de garantir
la sécurité minimum de l'effigié et
aussi des caddies qui vivent dans ces
régions et je ne veux pas du tout en
conflit armé avec le soudan notre
conséquences que nous prenions ces deux
transferts
de l'ader communautaire à l'apprendre de
l'autre côté de la frontière
version plus d'un millions de soudanais
déplacés est encore de l'autre côté de
cette frontière
si aucun règlement politique n'est
trouvée dans les semaines qui viennent
ils tenteront à leur tour de se réfugier
ici au risque de déstabiliser le tchad
et d'y provoquer une incontrôlable crise
humanitaire